police search an area of westland in
parkland on the final day of what's
become the bloodiest year for teen
killings in the capital
two teenage boys aged 15 and 16 were
pronounced dead within minutes of each
other last night in separate incidents
the mets say it's too early to tell if
the incidents are linked
but the double tragedy brings the total
number of teenage killings in london to
30 this calendar year posing serious
questions for the met and the mayor of
london
the problem is even though there are
fewer young people being stabbed even
though there are fewer young people
going to hospital with these injuries we
have a large number who losing their
lives the ferocity of some of these
stabbings the ferociousness
of some of these attacks is what causes
me concern and that's why we're going to
continue to support our police
officers continue to hunt for clues
searching here in usd in west london
where the 16 year old boy was killed and
more than 20 miles away in crowden where
just moments before a 15 year old also
lost their life and these aren't just
numbers these are young lives and their
loss has a traumatizing impact on
communities
i have children the same age
children that knew this young person
and for me
you know i'm nearly 50 and i have never
been
to a funeral of somebody i went to
school with
and here is my child
in six months in her school
death of two
of her classmates
the police say they continued to work
with local communities to get knives off
the streets but shortly after speaking
to sky news a church pastor says she was
contacted by a worried mother pleading
for her help i've had a phone call from
a mother
who is going through her washing basket
and has come across a knife
phone call pass the barrel please can
you come and pick this up come and
collect it
this is a mother who is in tears
and her thinking is is this going to
stop my child being killed or my child
killing somebody else
2021 closes as it began
with police promising to bring justice
to victims families and take weapons off
the streets
nevertheless we enter 2022 with a new
grim record
one that no one asked to be set
shimane freeman powell sky news